un pronunciamiento sin precedentes por
parte del departamento de justicia de
Estados Unidos
el departamento ha concluido que existe
una causa razonable para creer que en
lushville metro y la policía
metropolitana se involucraron en un
patrón o práctica de conducta que viola
la primera y cuarta enmienda de la
Constitución
Esta es la principal conclusión de las
autoridades tras Investigar los hechos
detrás de la muerte de la joven
afroamericana briona Taylor asesinada
por la policía durante una redada el 13
de marzo de 2020 el departamento de
Justicia es Claro en señalar que las
actuaciones de la policía son
sistemáticamente discriminatorias contra
la población afroamericana estos
hallazgos justificaron la decisión Del
fiscal general de poner fin a las
restricciones sobre los decretos de
consentimiento que impedían
responsabilizar a los departamentos de
Justicia locales ahora la fiscalía
general estadounidense se sentará a
negociar con la fiscalía y la policía de
Luis vil un acuerdo de consentimiento
este acuerdo con promedio a la ciudad y
a la fiscalía de Luis pill a trabajar
con la fiscalía general la comunidad Los
oficiales de la policía y otras partes
interesadas para abordar los problemas
que hemos identificado
la eventual firma de este consentimiento
entre autoridades locales y federales es
un paso importante para combatir la
violencia policial sistemática en
Estados Unidos contra la población negra
y una esperanza para que casos como el
de briona Taylor George Floyd y decenas
más no se repitan